the energy that an item possesses due to
its motion is called kinetic energy the
kinetic energy of an object which is
measured in joules varies jointly varies
jointly with the mass of the object and
the square of its velocity and then they
ask us if the kinetic energy of a three
kilogram ball traveling 12 meters per
second is 216 joules how heavy is a ball
that generates 250 joules of energy when
traveling at 10 meters per second and
they really shouldn't be saying how
heavy they should say what is the mass
of a ball because we care about maths
not weight
so we'll answer how what is the mass of
a ball that generates 250 let me write
this down this should be mass what is
the mass of a ball that generates 250
joules of energy 250 joules of energy
when traveling 10 meters per second so
let's think about it let's think about
what they tell us in this first
paragraph over here the kinetic energy
of an object so I'll just call that so
the kinetic energy I'll call that energy
energy not there's not three bars there
its energy and I'll write a little small
K here to say this is kinetic energy so
they say the kinetic energy which is
measured in joules and I won't focus on
the unit's here because this is really
the point of this is not to be a physics
problem the point of the system for you
to understand joint variation and I
don't want to introduce you to all the
dimensional analysis that might confuse
you right now so let's just work on
let's just work on the the the
proportionality that's going on over
here the variation so they say that
kinetic energy of an object varies
jointly with the mass of the object and
the square of its velocity so that
sentence right there says that it varies
varies jointly so it's proportional to
its proportional to the mass of the
object the mass of the object I'll call
that M M and the square of its velocity
I'll call that so the velocity let's
call that V and so the square of its
velocity will be V squared and then they
tell us then they tell us so we need to
figure out if we want to really apply
this we need to figure out what this K
value is right here we need to figure
out what K is then they tell us if the
kinetic energy of a three kilogram ball
traveling 12 m/s so here mass is three
kilograms our mass is three kilograms so
we have a three kilogram ball traveling
12 meters per second so our velocity is
12 meters per second 12 meters per
second and so our velocity so this is
going to be times 12 12 squared if the
kinetic energy of a three kilogram ball
traveling 12 meters per second its 216
joules so this right here is the energy
so it's going to be 216 joules 216
joules and then we don't know what this
constant is we don't know what this
thing right let me do that in that green
color we don't know what this constant
is so now we know everything else in
this equation we set up and we can now
solve for K and I want to show you that
the unit's do work out because 216 a
Joule is really the same thing as a
kilogram times a meter squared per
second squared and so you actually do
get joules on both sides of this and the
units for the K are actually there
they're actually our unit are no units
for the K it is it is unit less but with
that said let's solve for K so 3 times
12 squared so 12 squared is 144 and then
let's just figure out what three times
144 is we might be within our head but
just so we're working we don't make any
mistakes 3 times 4 is 12 3 times 4 is 12
we have this one that we carried so it's
13 3 times 1 is 3 plus 1 is 4 432 so all
of this over here is 432 and so if we
want to solve for K we can divide both
sides by 432 let me rewrite this let me
flip it around actually so we have 432
times K times K is equal to 216 is equal
to 216 and then to solve for K you just
divide both sides by 432
432 divided by 432 and we get K is equal
to and this looks fancy but well it
looks hard too it looks hard to simplify
but if you just double 216 you get 400
30 to divide the numerator by 216 you
get 1 divide the denominator by 432 you
get or divide the denominator by 216 you
get divided by the same thing you get 2
this is this is literally just 1/2 so K
over here is equal to 1/2 so now we're
ready to answer the second part we we
were able to use this first sentence
over here we were able to use this first
sentence here to figure out to figure
out our K and now we can answer the
second part they're asking us how heavy
or actually we should say what is the
mass of a ball that generates 250 joules
of energy when traveling 10 meters per
second so over here we're talking about
250 joules 250 joules is going to be
equal to K which is we know is now
one-half we just figured that out K is
equal to 1/2 is equal to 1/2 times the
mass that's what we need to figure out
what is the mass of the ball that
generates this times the mass when
traveling 10 meters per second so our
velocity is 10 so mass times 10 squared
and so we get 10 squared is 100 and so
we have 1/2 times 100 is going to be 50
so we get 50 times our mass try to keep
the same colors here 50 it's not the
same color 50 times our mass is going to
be equal to 250 is equal to 250 and then
to solve for mass you divide both sides
by 50 divide both sides by 50 divide
both sides by 50 on the right hand side
you just get mass on the left hand side
you just get 250 divided by 50 you get 5
so our mass is 5 and we didn't keep
track of the unit's here but you had
joules over here so this is 250 joules
and then this is joules divided by meter
squared per if you look at these units
it would be meter squared per second
squared you actually would get kilograms
so let me write this down so you
actually do get 5 kilograms so the mass
of the object in question is 5 kilograms